ja seit tagen sprechen wir über die
waffenlieferungen aus dem westen und
heute wollen wir ihnen erklären was die
ukraine mit diesen waffen machen und
warum sie so unglaublich wichtig sind
werden wir schauen auf ein video das
zeigt gleich eine rakete die vom boden
in den himmel auf ein hubschrauber
fliegt ich markiere das vorher einmal
und dann kannst du uns erklären hier
also gleich der hubschrauber achten sie
hier drauf und achten sie was von hier
unten angeflogen kommt und dann gehören
erzählt du gerne was genau wiedersehen
im prinzip genau das was du schon
beschrieben hast eine luftabwehr raketen
vermutlich schulter gestützt die einen
russischen russischen kampfhubschrauber
trifft die 24 oder wahrscheinlich 35 und
mit wir sehen der hat keine möglichkeit
auch nur teusch körper auszusenden die
distanz ist zu kurz
ausweichmanöver sowieso nicht oder
dergleichen wird getroffen die piloten
haben auch da wenig chance sich zu
retten also sehr effektive bekämpfung
was das genau für eine rakete war
darüber kann man nur spekulieren
wir sehen keine kann ja keine bilder die
da auf ausgesprochen guten anhaltspunkt
geben aber es ist könnte könnte durchaus
sich um eine der stinger raketen handeln
die die deutschland geliefert hat danach
wurden in sozialen medien zwar immer
wieder auf keiner seite sozusagen
ukrainische
waffen gesendet gezeigt sozusagen also
egal wie zum beispiel das kann
allerdings auch sein dass man sich
darauf verständigt hat mit deutschland
dass man gesagt hat wir wollen nicht
unbedingt bilder sehen wie deutsche
raketen russischer russisches militär
fahrzeug vom himmel holen wir jetzt
gerade hier du hast schon eingeblendet
auf irgendwelche dinge gezeigt wir haben
das grafischen ein stückweit aufbereitet
damit man dieses so schnelle video ein
bisschen mehr vielleicht verstehen kann
dass hier also der russische
hubschrauber die hmi du hast das gesagt
70er jahre entwickelt schon in diversen
kriegen auf dieser welt im einsatz
schwere maschinengewehr vorne dran
luft-boden-raketen alles mögliche darin
schwere kampfhubschrauber genau aber in
17 entwickelt aber mit diversen kampf
wertsteigerung immer weiter also das ist
ja durchaus immer noch eine sehr
gefürchtete waffe der sozusagen hier
jetzt im tiefflug unterwegs ist ist das
normal dass er so tief unterwegs ist das
fand ich sehr auffällig weil genau was
du gesagt dass es gibt ihm unglaublich
wenig zeit da unten rechts sehen wir
schon die rakete die da angefeuert
kommen darauf noch irgendwie reagieren
zu können ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
was was deren mission war das ist
allerdings die sind ja mitunter auch zum
schutz eigener konvois bzw zur
aufklärung unterwegs insofern das könnte
könnte das sein es könnte auch sein dass
sie versucht haben eben gerade aufgrund
der gefahr solcher solcher angriffe
möglichst ja im tiefflug
um nicht entdeckt zu werden zuvor
allerdings jahr hat es in dem fall nicht
geklappt das hier das ist die stinger
raketen darüber haben wir gesprochen
wenn es die war in der in diesem moment
von den amerikanern entwickelt die
deutschen die haben jetzt unter anderem
genau diese rakete geliefert vielleicht
einmal vereinfacht gesprochen wie
funktioniert diese waffe grob also die
es wie gesagt schulter gestürzt sind
nach vorne dann den kopf beziehungsweise
unten batterie dran
dieser sucht kopf ist vor allem infrarot
an beziehungsweise
uv bereich arbeitet der versucht ein
signal zu empfangen von einer von der
quelle eines ziels ich habe schon gesagt
er hat der hubschrauber in dem fall
andere luftfahrzeuge flugzeuge noch die
möglichkeit zum körper abzuwerfen die
dann ein anderes infrarot signal senden
um diesen um diesen kopf sozusagen zu
irritieren allerdings auch die auch die
singer wenn die auch schon einige
jahrzehnte alt ist hat auch immer wieder
neue neue kamp wertsteigerung erfahren
die letzte glaube ich vor 34 jahren und
da gibt es mittlerweile auch technik die
solche teusch körper wiederum
unterscheiden kann zwischen vom
eigentlichen ziel genau wir sehen dann
dass die rakete abgefeuert wird und dann
die ist das hier markiert vorne neben
dem hubschrauber und dann explodiert so
ein splitter sprengkopf und davon
treffen daneben schrapnelle den
hubschrauber bringe ihnen genau zum
abschluss zur explosion in dem fall ja
hat er glaube ich relativ wenig chance
da sozusagen
direkt das cockpit treffen in den
piloten die die bordelektronik
gesamtsteuerung da ist ja wenn ich wenig
möglichkeit für die piloten sich dann zu
retten zeigt wie ebenso eine
verhältnismäßig kleine waffe auf der
schulter am ende so einen riesigen
hubschrauber vom himmel holen kann und
wir sehen das war keine ausnahme sondern
wir sehen in den letzten tagen im
gegenteil eine ganze menge hubschrauber
und flugzeuge die von den russen im
einsatz sind die ihre bomben abwerfen
über die ukraine aber die eben auch von
den ukrainern abgeschossen werden
während ich hier noch einmal anschauen
dieses video ein propagandavideo der
russen flug fällt aus den letzten tagen
da sehen wir eben wie die jets zu
springen noch mal ein stück zurück der
russen fertiggemacht werden hier mit
diesen bomben über die wir auch gleich
noch mal eine runde sprechen werden und
dann eben kurz danach wie genau so einen
kampfjet vom himmel geschossen wurde
während diese aufnahmen im hintergrund
laufen das ganze zeigt uns auf jeden
fall die russen können sich eben nicht
so frei am himmel über der ukraine
bewegen wie sie das vielleicht selbst
gewollt hätten und wie man es vielleicht
auch erwartet hätte nach so wenigen oder
so ein paar tagen in diesem krieg genau
du sagst es gerade schon zu diesen
bildern sie können es nicht so frei
bewegen wir sehen jetzt nämlich sondern
abgeschossenen es 34 ist das glaube ich
bomba
die haben immer noch nicht die
lufthoheit nach fast zwei wochen krieg
die ukrainer haben immer noch sehr sehr
viele möglichkeiten befand ich
luftfahrzeuge zu bekämpfen sowohl mit
mit diesen schulter gestützten
luftabwehrsystemen die dass dinge die
wir gerade eben gesehen haben aber auch
mit mit größeren mit größeren
flugabwehrraketen bzw system sowohl aus
eigenen beständen und dazu sind ihnen
auch sehr viele luftabwehrsysteme in den
letzten tagen der russischen vor den
russischen streitkräfte in die hände
gefallen ich weiß nicht wie schnell das
sozusagen dann integriert werden kann
wieder in die ukrainische armee diese
systeme allerdings sind das ja diese
mitunter die selben system aber die
gleichen systeme die die ukrainische
armee auch verwendet insofern ja also da
gibt es noch einiges was die eu keine an
boden gegen die russische luftwaffe
aufbieten kann wir wollen einmal auf die
rolle der piloten zu sprechen kommen es
geht um den man hier ganz rechts denn
der saß offenbar in einem der flugzeuge
die gerade abgeschossen wurde wir wollen
ihnen die aufnahmen wie er danach
gefangen genommen wurde nicht zeigen
aber dieses foto hier das können wir
ihnen zeigen denn das zeigt ihn stolz
posieren neben dem syrischen schlechter
neben assad und eben neben wladimir
putin und das zeigt ein stück weit was
für männer damen einsatz in büren du
verfolgst den syrischen bürgerkrieg wie
kein anderer welche rolle spielt die
russische luftwaffe da was machen diese
piloten mit den syrischen zivilisten
also tatsächlich die entscheidende rolle
im syrischen bürgerkrieg ab 2015 hat
damals hat russland direkt eingegriffen
auf seiten des diktators assad mit
seiner luftwaffe und das war tatsächlich
an der wendepunkt weil im unterschied zu
den ukrainern haben die syrischen
syrischen opposition die syrischen keine
luftabwehrsysteme geliefert bekommen vom
westen und das führte dann eben dazu
dass piloten wie diese passen zeigt er
wurde jetzt über der ukraine
abgeschossen zivile wohnblöcke zivile
also ganze wohnblöcke ganze städte aus
der luft einen erscheinen konnten diese
taktik der der russischen der russischen
luftstreitkräfte da nicht nicht gezielt
militärische infrastruktur anzugreifen
die hängt zum einen damit zusammen dass
das teurer ist weil es eben wenn man
dafür im präzisions gelenk der munition
braucht er mit elektronik und
navigationssystem eine bombe ins ziel zu
denken und die günstigere alternative
dazu sehen wir hier in dem fall nicht
explodierte munition was wir auch vorher
in dem video gesehen hatten diese es 35
hat ja auch getragen der bomber das sind
500 kilogramm ähm 62 bzw ab 500 bomben
die gibt's auch noch einer kleineren
version 52 kilogramm ja davon habe ich
vorhin auch daran gehabt also diese
freifall munition die wird sozusagen
tatsächlich einfach vom ausgeklinkt und
findet dann sozusagen hat zwar ein paar
stabilisatoren hinten aber die wird
nicht gelenkt oder irgendwas man kann
damit nicht tatsächlich irgendwas zielen
sondern der einzige
militärischen nutzen ist dass man eben
ganze städte damit einen ärgern kann
also man kann sich vorstellen eine halbe
tonne hochexplosive militärischer
sprengstoff was der mit einem was wenn
es explodiert was das mit einem
wohngebiet anrichtet das kann einen
ganzen wohnblock einäschern das hat man
sich in syrien immer wieder gesehen
genau das also verheerend auf zivile
ziele und ich glaube das ist zum
abschluss ganz wichtige analyse wenn wir
über die rolle der piloten sprechen auch
darüber sprechen ob man mit denen
mitleid haben kann oder nicht wer so was
der 500 kilo über einem wohngebiet
abwehr 500 kilo die nicht gesteuert
nicht gelenkt sind sondern die wie im
zweiten weltkrieg einfach von bombay
abfallen und dann in irgendein ziel
hineinstürzen und dort tod und
verwüstung bringen das eben ist die
rolle die die russische luftwaffe in
diesem krieg in syrien gespielt hat und
aktuell in diesem krieg auch in der
ukraine spielt